[Musique]
le japon vient une nouvelle fois de
surprendre le monde occidental par une
réalisation tout à fait original vous
allez la voir dans quelques instants
ah non il ne s'agit pas d'un gadget
électronique mais d'un hôtel et quel
hôtel et surtout qui d'entre nous
occidentaux accepterait d'utiliser les
chambres que vous allez voir nous sommes
difficiles à comprendre disent
volontiers les japonais aux étrangers
après avoir vu ce reportage d'eric
gilbert nous ne pourrons pas prétendre
le contraire
une pancarte à l'entrée annonce
fièrement voici l'hôtel de l'an 2000 à
la vérité l'établissement ouvert dans
une galerie d'osaka pourrait faire
penser aussi à une morgue ou à une
consigne automatique
le client et a mis en boîte sans aucun
jeu de mots après avoir laissé ses
chaussures dans un coffre
il s'est choisi lui même son propre
casier
il y as 400 capsules de ce type empilées
les unes sur les autres dans une même
pièce
elles font trois mètres cinquante de
profondeur il n'est pas question de s'y
tenir debout
construite en plastique moulé elles sont
conçues pour une seule personne assise
ou couchée
toutes sont équipées d'une télévision
couleur d'une radio d'un réveil et aussi
de l'air conditionné
[Musique]
seul élément de décor traditionnel une
salle de bains collective au bout du
couloir
ces machines à dormir connaissent un
grand succès
principales raisons elles sont moitié
moins cher que les vrais chambre d'hôtel
et puis il ya aussi la curiosité mais on
aurait tort de les considérer comme de
simples gadgets
au japon on manque cruellement de place
et on s'habitue à vivre dans un espace
de plus en plus restreint et l'hôtel
capsule est une réalisation d'un projet
tout à fait sérieux présenté à
l'exposition universelle d'osaka en 1970
mais il arrive aussi parfois que les
architectes japonais des cauchemars
regardez ce qu'a fait il a été tout
simplement construit à l'envers
effectivement c'est le monde à l'envers
et si vous avez le sentiment que vous
étiez peut-être un petit peu à l'étroit
chez vous voilà le type de reportage qui
remet un peu les idées en place
[Musique]